ganz vielen dank noch mal an
sie frau volk und dr und das ganze
organisationsteam
für diese schöne veranstaltung
wir sind ja als teil einer traditionell
etwas in sich geschlossenen fakultät mit
auch recht speziellen bedürfnissen und
die diesen sonderstatus der der
parallelen patientenversorgung immer
besonders dankbar wenn wir ein bisschen
über unseren eigenen tellerrand schauen
dürfen und ich denke auch dass wird es
manchmal ganz besonders nötig haben also
insofern ganz herzlichen dank dass wir
als partei haben dürfen
es sind wir in den bisherigen beiträgen
schon einige themen adressiert wurden
die uns natürlich auch beschäftigen also
die ganz sicher von fachübergreifender
bedeutung sind und
überall gleichermaßen berücksichtigt
werden müssen zwischen den teilen freue
ich mich natürlich auch zu hören dass
auch in gießen verschobene
wissenschaftler und kliniker gibt das
tut ja auch mal gut das zuhören
und wir möchten heute
berichten über das arztzimmer als
hierher und lernraum den wir
neuerdings und bring mir eben auf
initiativen von der bewährten auch im
zentrum für unterricht und studium was
sich räumlich in der innenstadt am
sendlinger tor
in den räumen der ehemaligen radiologie
befindet zur verfügung haben
womit beschäftigen wir uns jetzt wenn
wir über leere in der humanmedizin regen
beziehungsweise hervor welche besonderen
anforderungen stellt diese lehre und
traditionell ist es ja so dass das fach
wie viele andere nicht nur
inhaltlich es sehr sehr dichtes darf ich
kurz zwischenfragen sehen sie den balken
in der presse das wunder ist er bei
ihnen nicht sichtbar bei mir stört es da
gerade unglaublich wenn das sanieren die
man sieht ist es mehr recht
als wir haben natürlich inhaltlich sehr
dicht was aber trotz das ziel für
praktisch tätige ärzte auszubilden
ist sehr sehr theorielastig gelehrt wird
also der schwerpunkt in der lehre lag
und liegt traditionell immer auf der
systematik der krankheitsbilder also
vermittlung der krankheitsbilder der
pathophysiologie der symptome der
therapie und was an begleitung folge
erkrankungen dazu
etwas später kommen dann dazu techniken
der untersuchung sowohl was die manuell
den körperlichen untersuchungsrichter
wird als auch technischer alternativ
müssten für die untersuchung und
absichtlich klein und verhältnismäßig
immer noch zu groß dargestellt
entwickelt sich langsam der trend dahin
auf
rücksicht zu nehmen dass die
studierenden irgendeine form von
ärztlicher leitung entwickeln müssen und
natürlich auch kommunikative strategien
erlernen müssen
was klassischerweise im studium bis zum
praktischen jahr früher nicht vorkam war
den studenten zu begleiten diese inhalte
auch in die praxis umsetzen zu können
also den praxistransfer zu schaffen und
gleichzeitig dass ich selber eine
struktur zu schaffen denn wer die
inhalte verankert werden können das ist
notwendig dafür dass der studierenden in
der lage ist nicht nur patienten
vernünftig aufzunehmen sondern auch die
entsprechende diagnostik und therapie
einzuleiten und im idealfall dann auch
einen sinnvollen arzt brief zu schreiben
der dritte komplex um den jungen sind
hier seit ich besonders kümmern betrifft
an punkte die die prüfungsvorbereitung
an der natürlich die studierenden
berechtigterweise und wo es interesse
haben aber auch die förderung von
lernprozessen mittels therapie
studierende nachhaltig und gute lernen
können und zu berücksichtigen ist bei
uns wie überall anders aus dieser kleine
punkt derzeitigen ressourcen und die
sind bei uns
genauso schnell neben vielen anderen
bereichen sicher auch wobei der der
universitär tätige arzt könnte immer
noch das problem hat dass er nicht nur
eine qualitäten sein gebiet sein muss
sondern am besten auch das netz schafft
wird immer in der tasche hat und dann
innovativ lehrt
wir haben jetzt als schwerpunkt in der
quali kursentwicklung
versucht möglichst früh
ich kann jetzt nicht mehr weiter
schreibt
möglichst früh
auf eine kompetenz
zentrierte lehre zu kommen das heißt wir
möchten genau die punkte
praxistransfer und integration von
lernprozessen
[Musik]
unterstützen und damit erreichen dass
wir der kompetente ärzte ausbilden wobei
wir da unter kompetenz die fähigkeit
verstehen ressourcen also dass akten bis
und die fertigkeiten ärztliche leitung
nicht nur zu erwerben sondern die dann
auch aktiven zu aktivieren und
funktional miteinander zu kombinieren
dabei steht an allererster stelle was
wir auch vorher schon angeklungen ist
eine strukturierte förderung höherer
kognitiver lernprozesse wir versuchen
heißt auch die dozenten dazu zu
animieren von der reinen vermittlung von
faktenwissen wegzukommen und den
schwerpunkt auf die in der lösung von
anwendungswissen zu legen also das heißt
auf zu achten dass das wissen was für
mitglied wird in den sinnvollen kontext
spielt also in jedem fall in der liga in
den klinischen kontext dass die
studierenden in der lage sind das was
sie inhaltlich lernen zu holen zu
analysieren eis auch dann zu
synthetisieren und umzusetzen und wir
damit eben ganz strukturiert den
praxistransfer des wissens begleiten und
im idealfall am ende dann ärztlich
kompetente junge kollegen ausbilden
woran wir uns da auch immer erinnern
müssen als dozenten ist dass wir ja
glücklicherweise oder neider als dozent
etwa
dass ein verlust ist offen erfolgreiche
lehre nehmen natürlich
durch unsere kompetenz oder durch durch
lehrmethoden wie zum beispiel klaren
strukturierung vorgabe smarter lernziele
und so weiter aber der wesentlicher
einflussfaktor für die auf reiche wäre
einfach der studierende ist der da etwa
50 prozent ausmacht und
die einflussfaktoren des
studierenden es sind hauptsächlich
vorwissen und intelligent heute können
wir nicht beeinflussen was wir aber sehr
wohl beeinflussen können und auch wollen
ist die motivation
und jetzt weiß ich ja jeder der lehrt
dass sowohl lehrern als auch lernen ohne
motivation tatsächlich möglich ist aber
natürlich nicht nur sehr hohe
anforderung als präsentations potenzial
steht sondern einfach anstrengend ist
und letztlich dazu führt dass die
inhalte nicht nachhaltig gelernt werden
also schlecht verankert sind und in der
liebe auch schlecht angewendet werden
kann welche drei punkte können wir jetzt
auch in der praxisnahen und
kompetenzorientierten die lehre fördern
um die motivation möglichst hoch zu
halten
das ist zum einen die auswahl relevanter
lerninhalte zum zweiten die gewährung
mit wissens selbstbestimmung in der
auswahl traktor und dem timing des
lernens und in der schaffung von
möglichkeiten die eigene kompetenz zu
erleben und genau diese drei punkte
können wir in dem wollen schon
angesprochenen zentrum für unterricht
und studium gut
integrieren bzw auf die kunden rücksicht
nehmen da wir da zum einen ein angebot
haben wo die studierenden
selber also im selbststudium inhalte
erarbeiten können das heißt sie sind
zwar nicht ordentlich ungewohnt
eingebunden sie können sich materialien
und modelle selbst zusammenstellen und
in der häufigkeit die sich selber
vermutlich erachten inhalte arbeiten wir
bieten eine ganze menge an praktischen
lerninhalten anhalts skills training
also training einfacher fähigkeiten
übungen an den modellsimulationen
von klinischen kontext und wie oben zum
beispiel der gestiftete und wir arbeiten
darauf hin dass wir diese gelehrten
inhalte dann auch in prüfungs konzepte
umsetzen und verstärkt den longitudinal
elemente wie eben zum beispiel die
kommunikation einbinden
das arztzimmer was jetzt da in dem
kontext entstanden ist also in den
räumen des zentrums für unterricht und
studium hat eine basisausstattung eine
hausärztliche praxen die sich das
wahrscheinlich vorstellen worden es gibt
zwei stühle und ein tisch und ein
untersuchungs liege dann steht da noch
ein kleines ultraschallgerät
und im nachbarraum entsteht so ein
kleines labor mit mikrofon und fuge also
dass man so die die einfachen haus
ärztlichen
untersuchungen da in einem relativ
realistischen settings
durchführen kann und der sinn und das
ziel dahinter ist eben wie vor schildert
die einbringung dieser doch sehr
theoretischen lerninhalte einen sinn
geben und praxisnahen
kontext was bieten wir an inhalten an
also zum einen können im rahmen dieses
arztzimmer kleine skills geübt werden
die ja auch tatsächlich in praxen
erfolgen also wie zum beispiel die
nutzung der messe blutzucker sticks
blutdruckmessung not abnahme abhängen
und bin deswegen von infusionen
beratung zu und die nachdem die
fortgeschritten dass dann ist geht bis
hin zu einem von innovation und atmung
dann können diese die skins also diese
wartens fertigkeiten angewandt werden
zum einen in der übung
modell zum anderen in der übung in einem
klinischen kontext also beispielsweise
wir geben eine kleine feier bildete vor
der studierende geht also in das
arztzimmer findet dort patienten vor
männlich 40 jahre beim haus als erhöhter
blutdruck auffälligkeit im urin und muss
sich jetzt überlegen was er mit dem tut
also was musste ihn fragen was muss er
klinisch untersuchen welche
untersuchungen anordnen
zu welcher differentialdiagnose kommt er
und wie geht es weiter
und so kann er diese diese kleinen
fähigkeiten und kleine einheiten an
theoretischen wissen kombinieren und die
als nächstes an wänden in einem problem
basierten lärms hätte also das heißt in
ein problem
basierten fall wo ist jetzt nichts
passiert auf ankunft inhalte korrekt
anzuwenden sondern strategien zu
entwickeln dieses problem überhaupt
erstmal integrieren als er sollte sich
überlegen worin besteht überhaupt meine
fragen wie adressiert die frage und
welche staaten habe ich gezielt und
schnell zu einer lösung zu kommen
und wenn er sich diese strategien
erarbeitet hat kann er das anwenden auf
klinische fälle also letztlich auf
virtuelle patienten das schöne an die
marge zimmer ist dabei speziell im
klinischen basisjahr man ja bei uns ganz
ganz viele verschiedene fächer zusammen
lehren dass das in den verschiedenen
fachbereichen erworbenen wissen es sehr
sehr gut verknüpft werden kann was ist
ja auch praktisch
werden muss ja bei dem patent kommt auch
in der liga erstmal zum hausarzt oder
vielleicht auch zum falschen facharzt
der muss ja auch breit denkt und
vorsortieren was dann mit dem ab das
zweite was sehr schönes dann dem arzt
immer ist dass wir
diese dinge skills anwendung der
fertigkeiten fall basiertes lernen
wiederholt im curriculum aufgreifen
können entweder mit gleichem inhalt oder
mit dem erweiterten inhalt und auf
zunehmende schwierigkeiten also der
studierende trifft idealerweise mehr mal
im curriculum auf ähnliche inhalte der
unter anderen aspekten und auf einen
zunehmenden schwierigkeiten
bearbeiten kann was auch wiederum zu
einer besseren verankerung zu einer
besseren anwendbarkeit und zuhören
lernen tiefe führt
wir bieten an nutzungsmöglichkeiten in
dem arzt immer wie ich ja schon erwähnt
habe also das selbststudium an dazu die
studierenden konnten anhand dieser
kleinen einheiten
selber auswählen was sie lernen muss
noten können es ist im moment noch
begrenzt aber hoffentlich in zukunft
zunehmend möglich kleine skills im
coaching zu erlernen also wir sind dabei
zu toren auszubilden jetzt nicht primär
für die skills das betrifft im moment
andere bereiche ist aber angedacht also
sprich eltern fortgeschrittene
studierende rang zu ziehen für ebenso
einfachen wie blutdruckmessen oder so
ist bei den studierenden sehr beliebt
weil die hemmschwelle niedriger ist als
wenn sie das nomad fertig machen müssen
und hat zudem den vorteil dass sie
einfach öfter üben als ist sie nehmen
solche angebote in der regel er war als
im rahmen von
untersuchungs kursen beispielsweise und
das dritte weiß ich ja schon erwähnt
hatte ist ihm sowohl die roma modell als
auch das rollenspiel was zunehmend jetzt
etabliert werden soll unter studierenden
und die übung am verband das ist im
moment mache vorne
von leitungen drin
wenn ich weiß wäre da habe ich gehe noch
mal zwei hin ich bin ich eigentlich
so nicht weitermachen
der informant weiter wie
wollen sie als auch heute okay also was
wir im moment noch nicht zur verfügung
haben für alle bereiche ist die übung am
probanden da gibt es derzeit ein
besonderes format das heißt patienten
nur wm-vierte kommunikation und da gibt
es tatsächlich
so größtenteils ausgebildete also
sozusagen echte schauspieler die die
rolle von patienten übernehmen und zum
teil in beeindruckender weise die
studierenden beispielsweise anderen ließ
oder aufklärungsgesprächen herausfordern
das ist natürlich sehr sehr wertvoll ist
sehr teures und sehr intensives format
was wir aber immer planen und hoffen
ausdehnen zu können und was natürlich
ideal auch in dieses arztzimmer
integrierbar wären was ich aufholen
schon erwähnte was sonst sehr sehr
wichtig ist es dabei auch immer die die
kommunikativen kompetenzen oder bzw die
entwicklung von kommunikationsstrategien
im auge zu behalten und zwar sowohl was
den arzt patienten kontakte angeht es
hatte fällt schon erwähnt aber natürlich
auch was den die kommunikation unter den
kollegen angeht und hinter
professionelle kommunikation angeht dazu
kommen wir später noch
und das erlernen von der ärztlichen
leitung das ist ja auch was was nicht
von alleine kommt und was nicht gewissen
reflexion und auch selbst analysebedarf
das war die letzten 50 jahre wenig
modernen sich im studium darum zu
kümmern tut aber glaube ich so und den
ärzten als auch den patenten ganz gut in
dem zentrum haben wir jetzt zusätzlich
den luxus dass wir lerneinheiten
aufzeichnen können also das heißt die
studierenden können gefüllt werden
solange es die er tätig und hat danach
die möglichkeit
begleitet zu analysieren was sie da
getragen haben was der sehr wertvolles
erstens weil man natürlich einen anderen
blick auf sich hat wenn man sich denkt
man agieren sieht und zum zweiten weil
so in einem geschützten raum die
möglichkeit haben auch strategien zur
selbstreflexion zu entwickeln
wenn wir jetzt was neues
etablieren wie gehen wir vor wir
versuchen uns an bedarf zu orientieren
wir haben den luxus ist wenn recht guten
kontakt zur verschafft haben und ist
sehr sehr gut aufgestellte
evaluation also das heißt wir bekommen
recht gut mit
was die studierenden für bedürfnisse
haben was gut läuft es nicht gut läuft
wir versuchen uns auch an den
prüfungsergebnissen zu orientieren also
abzugleichen was wir lernen zu rücken
was verlieren und was am ende bei den
studierenden ankommen
an nächster stelle steht dann die
auswahl von konzepten die sowohl
praktikabel als auch im nachhaltig
implementierbar sind dann die bei uns
tatsächlich nicht immer so leicht
rekrutierung von mitarbeitern oder
kooperationspartnern
was natürlich auch oft einfach eine
frage der verfügbarkeit von
finanzierungen zeit ist und dann die
umsetzung die aber immer auch beinhaltet
dass wir diese formate ins curriculum
einbinden einfach dass sie nachhaltig
geleert werden uns nichts verloren geht
im moment sind wir dabei
standardprozedur zu etablieren die
ermöglichen dass möglichst viele
fachbereiche in diesem arztzimmer lernen
beziehungsweise die studierenden die
diese inhalte lernen können dort
wir versuchen dafür möglichst viele
fakten bisschen selbst ladeneinheiten
auszulagern die sich die studierenden
selber erarbeiten können dass es
natürlich jetzt packt in zeiten der
aktuellen lehre von hohen praktischen
wert wenn das schon begonnen worden ist
wir versuchen dann als nächsten schritt
ermöglichen dass die das erlernte
praktisch anwenden können und dann wie
ich vorhin schon gesagt habe an zwei
beispielen oder übungen untereinander
oder an probanden
was wir vorhaben die ebenfalls schon
erwähnt ist die etablierung von
kompetenz basierten prüfungs formaten
also sprich das was wir dort lernen
problem was jetzt lernen frei basiertes
lernen und ist kriegs auf zu prüfen zum
beispiel anhand von handlungskompetenz
innovationsorientierten standard setting
wir hoffen dass wir in dem rahmen auch
die
einübung von integration verschiedener
praktischer fähigkeiten
implementieren können also wir stellen
uns vor dass zwei oder drei teams von
den studierenden zusammen zu einem
virtuellen patienten oder zu einem fall
gegeben und sich dann entweder die
rollen als experten aufteilen oder gegen
im kollegialen team versuchen zu
arbeiten
und der dritte punkt ist natürlich im
moment so ein bisschen vordergrund
bedrückt auf wir versuchen dort
virtuelle formate auszubauen wie ich
vorhin schon erwähnt hat zb mit dieser
patienten orientiert wo kommunikation
für die wir natürlich auch wenn wir die
perfekten konter oder zu machen gewissen
rahmen brauchen einfach indem die
schauspiel patienten agieren können
dann darf ich an die frau wershoven über
gegend für den teil lernen im interview
was in kontakt
ganz herzlichen dank ich hier jetzt so
als bonbon nicht als modell sondern
einfach als schluss noch mal hier was
vorstellen was wir das arztzimmer dann
auch noch einfach nutzen können und zwar
in dem rahmen von interprofessionellen
line also es geht letztendlich
zusammengefasst um eine verbesserte
kommunikation zwischen den
einzelnen professionen zu erreichen man
weiß dass es einfach defizite darüber
gibt und dadurch sondern natürlich auch
eine beste verbesserte
patientenversorgung
stattfinden zum beispiel abläufen mit
irgendwelchen struktur mit irgendwelchen
besprechungen ich das irgendwie was doch
bild nachher dann einfach
verordnet wird oder nachgefragt wird
oder dass vielleicht im schlimmsten fall
irgendetwas übersehen wird oder
irgendwelche nebenwirkungen nachher dann
nicht beachtet werden und natürlich aber
dann auch den großen part wo die
patientenversorgung einfach übergeht die
patientensicherheit zu gewährleisten und
letztendlich auch darauf dass wir die ja
landen auf ihre zukünftige art
zusammenarbeit
vorbereiten es gibt mehrere
ist eigentlich mal papiere wohl sagen
das wird jetzt gefordert das ist jetzt
nicht mehr so das was sagen das ist
jetzt nice to have sondern ist schon so
dass von der whu bist im
sachverständigenrat dass man dann
einfach sagt das ist eine die sind
wichtige kompetenzen dass
ärzte beziehungsweise ich sage jetzt mal
die ganzen gesundheitsberufe in der lage
sind gut miteinander zu kommunizieren
jetzt was heißt es hier ganz praktisch
durch die see um die nächste folie dann
bitten genau und zwar das kann so
ausschauen dass wir üben zum beispiel
den übergaben von patienten anhand von
ist da stellt hier eine
kommunikationsstruktur vor die hätte
erstmal sich selber vorstellt also
identifikation dann wird kurz mit dem es
die situation beschrieben dann
irgendwelche background wo dazu wichtig
ist dann eine assessment eine bewertung
oder abschätzung auch und recommendation
was würde ich jetzt oder was sollte er
wechseln da hat dann gedruckt wird getan
werden
das ist so eine struktur wenn sich jeder
an diese struktur hält dann weiß man
was kommt jetzt einfach hier als
nächstes unterbricht nicht oder der eine
wenn man miteinander spricht
jeder hat eine andere vorstellung von
einem
skript im kopf des eigenen berufs und so
können wir das auf diese art und weise
zusammenbringen und nicht dass während
ich dann vielleicht noch an vorstellen
bin von den background dass der eine
schon erwartet dass wir
irgendwelche therapie an der stelle dann
vorschlagen da habe ich jetzt in zwei
beispiele so main vorgestellt sie können
sich vorstellen
zusammensitzt
pflegepersonal von der ambulanten
gesundheitsversorgung
mit dem hausarzt zusammen und die beiden
planen jetzt
gesundheitsversorgung von patienten die
jetzt gerade aus dem schlager aus dem
krankenhaus entlassen wird
mit einer halbseitenlähmung und auch
weil es kompliziert ich mit der schluck
steuerung also was so ungefähr eine
pflege für grad 4
bedeuten würde da geht es darum ich das
krankenhausbett da was fehlt welches
essen muss gemacht werden kommt unter
umständen hob er die noch mit dazu
sind die angehörigen überfordert und so
weiter und so fort also wir haben ihr so
ein schönes beispiel wo wir sagen wir
können hier diese struktur dieser
übergabe
einfach dann noch einmal üben oder eine
andere
klassische situation ist dass man zum
beispiel dass jemand auch vom
ambulanten pflegedienst jemand anruft
und sagt bei dem hausbesuch zu hause bei
pflanzen so habe ich gesundheitliche
probleme durch die hitze festgestellt
diese weitergabe ich an der stelle
wichtig wir wissen dass sehr viele geld
gerade ältere menschen über die hitze
eingeschränkt sind und es kann auch
auswirkungen
mit medikamenten nachher den haben das
kann bis zu krankenhausaufenthalten dann
führen bzw
sogar nachher dann auch zu einem
verstorben sind wir etwas übersehen es
ist ganz ideal ist kann man mit diesem
ist gut übergeben eine andere situation
mehr dann fallbesprechungen die auch
nach gewissen strukturen folgen wo wir
einfach im team zusammen sitzen und bei
der komplexen
gesundheitsversorgung einfach uns
absprechen was passiert denn an welcher
stelle und wann und wer macht denn etwas
ein fall geschichte wäre in diesem fall
schön
patient der alleine zu hause lebt der
insulinpflichtigen diabetes hat und zum
beispiel über den ambulanten
pflegediensten versorgt wird und jetzt
stellten aber dann fest dass eine
beginnende demenz einfach daran dass
wir können an dieser stelle auch ohne
weiteres sagen wir sitzen nicht nur
hausarzt im amtszimmer zusammen und von
minister pflegedienst wir können an der
stelle auch
einen zum beispiel angehörigen dann auch
mit einbinden genau das gleiche könnten
wir das auch bei der palliativen
gesundheits versorgung eines patienten
machen und wo man mag die angehörigen
sind an dieser stelle durchaus jetzt
überfordert welche möglichkeiten gibt es
das ist schon zusammen tragen dann an
der stelle
wir können jetzt mit diesen kurzen
beispiel können wir sagen wir
nehmen zum beispiel ein schachspiel
patienten der die rolle der pflegeperson
oder der von einem anderen beruf
spielt wir können es aber auch so sagen
das wir möglich die profession an der
stelle einladen und jemals wirklich dass
jeder die eigene rolle spielt wir können
es dann weiter man bei einer reflexion
bekannt sein okay wie wäre es denn wenn
wir auch mal die rollen tauschen wie
schaut's denn mit den
verantwortlichkeiten nach einer aus
dadurch lerne natürlich die anderen
wieder sehr viel von den berufen der
anderen und was es bedeutet auch nachher
ganzen zu engagieren da hätten wir das
haben wir heute schon mal gehabt dieses
lernen voneinander und übereinander und
miteinander und da gibt es nachher dann
sehr gute konstellationen das dient aber
wirklich allem dazu dass wir besser
miteinander kommunizieren durchaus auch
strukturierte miteinander kommunizieren
dass wir uns in ausbildung währenddessen
begegnen bei bisher ist das auch noch so
das medizinstudium abläuft und wir
treffen eigentlich dann er steht für der
zusammenarbeit zusammen wenn wir nachher
dann alle fertig sind und das ganz
irgendwo dann auch nicht so ganz sein
und deswegen versuchen wir vorher schon
die ganzen unterschiedlichen beruf von
pflege bis pharmazie das
wirklich von
physiotherapie wir versuchen die leute
einfach zusammen zu bringen dass sie
sich einfach dann an der stelle dann
austauschen